all right geraldine
yes geraldine uh where'd you grow up
where were you from originally
um here on the mountain lancer county
and tell me about your childhood you had
both your parents growing up yes
how would you describe your childhood um
well when i was about
five years old i started
throwing the mountain pool war out break
after my mom cook
on the water trail you know and uh
my job was helped it wool out and help
cook
and play in the house what year was this
you were born in what year
49 49 i was about seven year old when i
started in
you had electricity and running water
back then oh no we have patreon water
no juice we have tighter clothes through
the river marsh out on a rubbing board
really yes how did you get around
you you guys had cars back then uh we
got a horse
uh we had a horse and slayer
and uh i travel through the mountain
from boeing street into middle fork to
the mountain
and buy roasters and go back in the
middle that home in the
lord for it no horseback on horseback
yes
what did your father do for a living uh
he worked outside meal
a dollar a day when i was little
your father made a dollar a day yes
working in the saw mill yes
wow and i had two brothers older than i
was
but we have worked in the fields
planting garden
flying a horse and raising the garden
and canning their way through the summer
in the winter time then we have pulled
our wool in for the winter
and months would you stay warm in the
winter you burned uh we burned wool
and a little bit of coal where we throw
it back out on the mountains
though there wasn't no coal mine or a
bad thing
was that right so the coal mining
started when
well it started later on and on
it started about this pretty well 1960.
is that right and how far did you go in
school
i went to high school eighth grade
and you have children of your own yeah
you you got married
i got married got a divorce raised up i
was on my own no help
when did what year did you start having
kids or get married
how old were you i was almost 17 when i
got married 17.
back when i was young we all would live
in the two grown chat you know no
a chat house had two rooms in it
and uh didn't have no insulation nothing
like that you know
and they come at me flood in 1957 they
were
it caught way up in the house and we all
had leave home and don't want to be
cliff down the road
yeah he'd come through the house come
through the house but we had to leave
right we had to hit the mountains is
that right
yeah did it destroy your house well yeah
hit
water up nate tape in it
was a lot of chicken hawaii no house and
cows we have
milk cows we have throw out milk
and they're chickens that's what you did
for food yeah you grew your own food
mostly
yeah and how many kids do you have i had
five
uh one doctor on a car rent in 2003.
i'm sorry
what was the best part of your life
well i raised all my boys up
on my own and i have the last 20 years
it's been
fine still so well living
your life has been good yeah pretty well
you're happy
yeah yeah what i mean did you ever
consider leading appalachia
no never no what do you love most about
it
i love most black oh you got your
mountain here i love comb hunts world
huh
i ain't end on turkey mountaineers
i love coma and swirl huh
what do you do with with raccoon and
squirrel you ate
you eat them yeah still to this day
yeah yeah what does raccoon taste like i
didn't like them they thought
i love swirls
so i come on it swirl hunting
gently rotate
and yourself you know
you know
and your sons have stayed here in
appalachia yes
and what do they do for work well
yeah um they worked in timeline a little
bit randy
you know michael he never did have no
public job he had to rely on job they
drive a chat
and my oldest son he's on chat now he
disabled me
they work building houses none of your
family considered leaving
and warren my ultimate turry
he lived in rich when he'd been down
there he worked
he got his own flight down there so he
got out droughts and stuff like that and
did well
what's the roughest thing about living
here
a robot i'm living here
probably in the wintertime it's hard to
get around
yeah but now you're like three or four
years you've been okay
but the winners you got to hear how do
you heat your house
i got a hater and i got a coy war
so you burn coal to keep it warm yeah
yeah
have you ever traveled you've been to
other states yeah i've been north like
i've been there when i was in indiana on
georgia one time and
channel say yes i don't know
but you you you choose to stay here yeah
what makes appalachians uh different
than people you see in other parts of
the country
oh well to me
everybody about life they are real
thrilling they will help you if you need
help
you know they watch y'all be in
so you know you your neighborhood they
you know
they real nice and everybody is and they
help one another
yeah and everybody seemed like a lot you
know
it's the same you know every day doing
right it's just a shame that there's no
work here
yeah we know they're having to work
let's down
never did yeah coal mines no yeah but
they was off
far out further out yeah that was then
toward virginia and
harlan and hazard like it like that
right
and some people they lie when the
mountain cut wild down you know
around here or something to yale
now this lifestyle almost seems to be
left behind technology has taken over
most of the world but here in appalachia
it's
still very simple yeah a lot of people
live without electricity a lot
without running water yeah and they
don't choose to leave they're
they love it here yeah do you think
that'll continue
yeah i sure do yeah
well man you know we live in them you
look the other one of the big cities
they got a lot of problems
they fighting going on turning the city
apart
all that thing going on right now
california is burning down on people
and one good thing about it a lot of
people out there live back here in the
mountains
get away from my way out yeah you can be
very
you can live a very isolated life here
if you want to yeah uh-huh
and most people come from one place you
really like this place too
it's beautiful it's one of the most
beautiful places i've seen
yeah i want everybody's side are you uh
religious
woman i'm a holiness mm-hmm you're awake
i'm high on this yeah yeah you go to
church
yeah when i did tell you i think
what's been the hardest thing you've had
to go through in your life
well the only thing i went through about
this was filling my son up
yeah when he got killed in that car
wreck
i think that's about the hardest thing
now facing so far
how old are you huh how old are you me
i got a birthday coming up in october
i'll be 71.
you're 71. yeah i'll be 71 in october
wow
do you think all the adversity you have
to endure here
and get through it's just a struggle to
survive between making money and getting
around
and you know every every every house is
a struggle just to get through the
driveway almost
do you think that's what makes
appalachians so helpful and so
kind yeah everybody live about the same
way
everybody has a struggle yeah everybody
up in here they try to chat
no folks ramps and and um
they ain't no work what they work you
know
they probably teachers or something like
that you know
a mail truck they ain't much work going
on here in this county for people
yeah and drugs have kind of taken over
too oh yeah
drugs have been out of control here for
like a couple decades oh when they
brought that crank in here right what
none
like two years that was darn about
ending but in in this race in many ways
um yeah they they they let that aisle
come in here on you
and the people was raising a little bit
of power out here in the mountains
they raised the power to support their
family
and uh buy their clothes and shoes and
stuff they use it in the right way you
know what i'm
saying and um okay
they come in your wrap on people
then they will take your jail for if
they catch you
and also here come iris
or cocaine herron and
um and that math
and all that in your they don't know
nothing about that
and people dying in piles on that they
still don't do nothing about it
and i don't know why they all know where
it comes from they deal with it and all
that
i don't know why why do you think so
many people have
drug abuse problems here dr probably
ain't no work nothing furry to do
nothing to do not what i played
when i was married to my husband he made
moonshine
which i helped him look at their
afternoon
and um he made it to moonshine you know
but the worst problem about it when he
made it
he never was sober no more he hit up on
getting wild wild wild
wilder they dropped the eye up
that made him fit like horse and cat
they didn't end up at a divorce
do you feel like life has gotten better
or worse in the last
20 30 years oh it got better it's gotten
easier
yeah what were the biggest changes
because you you grew up in a time when
there were no uh
no cars there was no electricity no
water and things have gotten easier now
right yeah
what was the biggest change
yeah i got my car now i i i own a car
about
like 20 years i ain't ran on my stepping
vehicles
and i thought places and
getting my sisters and stuff down in the
country and go places
lots of yards say a lot love y'all
ourselves
what kind of stuff do you grow you have
a garden yeah we've got a bed garden
every year that's the way we live
what do you what do you grow i can corn
beans
and rice taters and sweet taters and
pepper and watermelon
mushrooms you name it i had it
cabbage i can't wait for
500 years of food a year really
it can't been to that i won't make it
well when my boy was i'm saying we got
float down too
and i draw a champ and um
i got my disability so sturdy on my
husband
do you have any regrets in your life no
not i don't know why i don't right now
yeah i do one
what's that it's multi-million
yeah those are shirt in your life yeah
yep which i had never seen one them
okay all right geraldine well thank you
so much for talking with me you will
you're very interesting thank you
you